I think he's misunderstood you know
misguided I will sort of go with it when
people say god he's such a douche she's
such a dick and yeah there is sides of
him that can be like that but I think we
can all be a douche and a dick at the
best of times you all know me
I we know you for a steaming sack of
you know I mean so when we were
pushed when we pushed into a corner
sometimes you've got to come out
fighting and I think that's kind of what
he does but I would definitely say that
yeah he's not the most likable of people
but I think he's got reasons and he's
got his issues about it well I just
think he's never had the chance to make
his own decisions about his fate about
his life throughout his whole life at
all nine years is it they took a
frightened boy what have they given back
and so when he finally gets the
opportunity to do that he makes some
brass decisions and you know he's never
had he's never had a home you know I
mean so that's got to be you know it
kind of messes with people's head he
won't stand a chance against the
Lannisters on you old said anything
about the Lannisters he's just a bit of
a little boy really you know I mean he's
just the kind of child stuck in this
man's body and he's trying to prove
himself but he's only I like him you
know and I think he's I definitely
relate to him on some levels for sure so
when he finally gets the sort of
opportunities like I said sort of going
to his own thing he takes full advantage
of it but yeah I think that's kind of
one of the only sort places of
authorities in the bedroom that's
probably and to be honest to you they're
all you know he's paying for it isn't he
so it's not like he's nothing
so I smiling with your lips closed
that's it but that's the first rule I
would make if I was handed the king free
brothels why not